[Music]
i would have missed this on august bank
holiday monday
the costumes
the color
[Music]
and the crowds
notting hill carnival in full flow
on its busier second day close to a
million people were expected to attend
and they shimmied through the streets
nisha and alexander have waited two
years to wear these outfits i just feel
like carnival runs in my blood
like i have to be involved in some way
or what uh you know however it comes
about and i prefer to play moss and yeah
i've been doing it for years and i will
never stop until my body says stop so
that's what i do
today it's been fabulous really good um
it's the first carnival obviously for a
couple of years
i haven't heard of anything bad that's
happening if we're getting along with
one another it's been fantastic for you
all it's energy and color carnival isn't
just a celebration of caribbean culture
it's written into the story of west
london
which is why some people here went
silent for 72 seconds
to mark the 72 lives lost in the
grenfell tower fire five years ago
some of the first fire fighters on the
scene side by side with survivors and
campaigners
with an event this size there are always
small pockets of trouble
police confirmed the rest had been made
for a variety of offences
away from the crowds people who have
been coming here for years summing up
what this event should be about carnival
is something for we
as caribbean people yeah express our
feelings in it yeah energize and eat
good food and
congregate amongst the people
as vibrant as it's ever been this staple
of the summer is back
and it's not mr beat shinki marike sky
news notting hill